so there's this element of the fact that
look streaming came along completely
changed the production schedules the
number of episodes uh comp didn't keep
up
um and I think of this as the streaming
strike if you were to be very uh you
know simplistic about it but it's also
somehow become the AI strike uh where
Apparently one of the earlier sticking
points and negotiations was writers
saying look you can't use AI to generate
scripts and then the studios are like
hard pass on that like we totally want
to be able to use it yeah
and and you have some opinions as to
what AI can and can't do well yeah so
the writer skill just wants to regulate
it and I'm not on the guild negotiating
committee so I'm not exactly sure what
they're asking for but the studios like
you're saying it's hard pass that's off
the table we're not going to let you now
ai currently can't write anything close
to being usable uh the quality that
we're writing currently but the studios
are at least optimistic that in the near
future it might be good enough and good
enough is good enough and so and you
know how yeah it works it's just a
plagiarism tool that scrapes the
internet for other stuff that we've
written and amalgam makes it and and
hopefully uh we'll make something good
up so no writer and their right mind
it's like signing your own death wish no
writer is going to agree to a contract
that says okay yeah sure phase me out
I'll sign right here phase me out you
know I mean I people probably know I've
been concerned about the impact of AI
for quite some time this is an early
navigation of uh how AI is going to be
used because if you're a studio you're
like heck yeah I want to be able to use
this thing yeah and if you're the
writers you're like well like I'm not
going to freaking help automate my
myself out of a job I mean you know like
I have to do this for years to come oh
when I did run for president I ran on
this notion that AI is going to eat a
lot of jobs and we should start giving
everyone money uh called it the freedom
dividend set it at a thousand bucks a
month now that's not a whole lot in
Hollywood
um but do you think that something like
Ubi what
would help uh people transition I mean
it's sort of you know obviously it's
like something of a leading question you
know though and I think about AI a lot
right now and it's it's so interesting
it's like we've created this God let's
worship it uh this artificial God you
know the Arts no one goes into the Arts
hoping to become rich like I said that's
why you're Starving Artists until you
start making some money and what the
Arts allow us to do is understand
ourselves and help create something and
turn something inside of us into
something more positive and hopefully
understand ourselves and our place in
society and hope other people do the
same but AI will never be able to write
about The Human Experience because it's
not human and whenever it scrapes from
the internet comes from other writers
but it'll never be authentic it'll only
be artificial and so if you really are
interested in writing something or
watching something that really moves you
I think it has to come from a human now
I am interested to know what this is
until AI becomes sentient I mean when
then things change but then AI will be
able to write a story about what it's
like to be a computer and I'd be
interested in reading that story but
right now I can't do anything close to
that it's not sentient and I can't write
about The Human Experience because it's
not human and so if if art moves you in
any way then I think you're going to
need to put a premium on human writers
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you